Just give us a little glimpse into what some of your other daily health habits look like.
Well, I like to eat donuts. And we all.
So my daily health habits should be much better than they currently are. I'm addicted to
studying and learning and listening to audiobooks and podcasts like yours. So by probably my biggest
daily health habit has to do with just being in prayer and just time, just quiet time.
That to me is the most important thing because all the stresses that you have in life and being a
clinician, I am an empath. So I take on all my patient's burdens really easy. And it affects me.
It could affect me very negatively. So I have to really make time to just purposefully
give them back to God in prayer. Otherwise, it could just eat at me. So that's probably my most
important. If I don't do that on a very regular basis, I notice my health slipping. So diet is
important. I try to eat almost exclusively gluten free, dairy free because of my cancer. I don't
eat much meat at all for when I first diagnosed with cancer. It's just completely dairy and any
animal protein free except for some fish. Now I've maybe once or twice a month. I'll eat a little
chicken. But so diet is my cancer happens to be driven slightly off of animal protein. So I have to
be careful of that. And then again, the biggest thing is that is tried to give back to God
the burdens of my patients. And then actively be praying for my patients. It's one of my biggest health
benefits. So